[Applause]
another day and another rally with
thousands of angry people taking to the
streets in sri lanka
they came from around the country
desperate to be heard
people are facing hardships even those
who have money don't have goods to buy
children students parents everyone is
facing problems
after 25 years abroad i started farming
i don't have fertilizer my child doesn't
have milk powder in the same way every
sector is affected everyone understands
this
the rally in nuger on the outskirts of
the capital colombo was organized by the
national people power coalition
its leaders say the mainstream political
parties are responsible for the current
state of affairs and are calling for
political change the crowds carried
banners that said 74 years of corruption
enough is enough
people are crying patients are dying and
the government is lying
i want the government to get a clear
message that the people have had enough
and it is time that they allow the
people to make a new choice and form a
new government that can at least start
to resolve some of these issues that's
going to be a daunting task for anyone
who dares the country's foreign reserves
have hit rock bottom with no money for
imports of vital food medicines cooking
gas and fuel which are increasing in
price globally as well as in sri lanka
people are angry at having to spend
hours in queues for essential items
i've not eaten from morning i can't go
to work the pay we get is not increasing
but they have increased prices of all
food items
and they say sri lanka is not the only
country facing economic trouble at
present but they point out that
mismanagement bad planning and
corruption has aggravated things
on wednesday president gotabe rajpaksa
hosted an all-party conference telling
participants they must unite to find
solutions to the current situation but a
number of those gathered here in nugeda
told al jazeera that the president's
words come too late to be taken
seriously
the national people's power is the
latest political front to organize
demonstrations like this against
economic
hardships widespread anger desperation
and frustration has brought thousands of
peoples onto the street
minerva fernandez al jazeera nuger